- Now, anything surprise you
about working with Johnny?
Was this, do you realize, oh,
this is exactly where I am,
we're on the same head space
or this guy is so much
further gone than I am?
What was the feeling?
- Well, it was funny because
the first day we get to set,
you know, Knoxville looks like
the Knoxville I grew up
watching on television.
He had dark hair.
He looked pretty much the same to me .
And then, you know, as
we started filming more,
one day, he shows up to set
looking like Silver Foxville here.
- Oh, Rachel.
- [Rachel] And I was like, what is,
I don't recognize this person.
And I think me and the internet both agree
that he has a strong
resemblance to Jamie Lee Curtis.
- [Jay] Jamie Lee Curtis?
Do we have a, is that, do we have a photo?
Let's take a look.
- [Johnny] Let's see.
Okay.
- [Rachel] I thought I was
on the set of Halloween.
- [Jay] Yeah, not bad.
Not bad.
Well, here's what I don't understand.
In the first half of the
movie, he had black hair?
- [Rachel] Mm-hmm.
- And then one day he showed up with gray?
- [Johnny] After COVID,
during the COVID break.
We started filming in March,
we started filming in 2020 in February
then we got shut down in March
and we resumed again in September.
So between that time, I became.
- [Jay] Yeah but most
films have what they call
a continuity person and they will say,
oh, you have the ring on the wrong finger.
They'll notice the smallest thing.
I mean, when you came in,
when you come in with black
hair and then the silver,
sends some guy, hey, wait a minute
it doesn't quite match.
- You know, we don't have
a continuity person, Jay.
- [Jay] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Jay] I'm stunned.
- Unbelievably.
- Oh, all right. Okay.